Russell Brand today the Met police in
the last few hours Kevin have announced
that they are launching a police
investigation into what they call
Historic allegations we don't know we
don't know who it's from we don't know
which of the stories but other people
who came forward to the Sunday Times at
Channel 4 whether they're new people
they haven't explained yet exactly who
these accusers are but it's certainly
multiple people and it takes it to where
I've wanted this to go which is legal
due process we're now going to have a
proper police investigation but what
still concerns me about the story is
what is going on off the back of the
original investigation which is this
sort of huge concerted effort to cancel
Russell Brand who is now doing exactly
what I knew he would do he's he's
exploiting that to say look it's all a
Witch Hunt they're all trying to shut me
down let's take a little look at his
clip on Rumble today
plainly this is a story that is much
bigger than me plainly The Trusted news
initiative has an agenda an explicit
agenda to throttle and choke Independent
Media plainly the government are
reaching out to ask big Tech platforms
to suppress the voices of content
creators from Independent Media Outlets
particularly those that are dissenting
and as you have seen many of those media
organizations have been willing to
comply Now esther this is all heading to
a very dark place I think you now have
Russell Brown facing a serious police
investigation into rape sexual abuse all
sorts of very serious allegations but
he's just carrying on like nothing's
happened he did a two-hour rant today
with all sorts of conspiracy fueled
stuff his normal sort of stick
um what do you feel about the way he's
behaving a lot of these allegations
there's no apology there's no
clarification there's just this ongoing
no it's all a Witch Hunt and also the
way the world is responding to these
allegations yeah well I saw this coming
because this is this is why I said
originally these women should have gone
to the police because now we live in an
era when someone is being attacked like
this it's automatically a conspiracy and
I just think there's nothing that
particularly special about Russell Brand
he's not an intellectual luminary for
the likes of CNN or any of these massive
media corporations to be scared of the
reality is he has been accused of
something very serious and the the law
should should should play out the
reality is at the end of the day he's
going to keep going and saying that this
is a conspiracy against him because like
he says he's maintaining his innocence
so if he's innocent he's operating Grace
what we what we have now is you see a
trend Donald Trump sort of started this
really Boris Johnson has done a bit of
it too where regardless of the
allegation or its seriousness you simply
say it's a Witcher you simply say it's
mainstream Legacy Media combining with
big Tech combining the government and
I'm a victim here so this kind of
turning the thing on its head and using
victimhood as a protective shield
against this and they've got millions of
people who go along with this well again
you know I think this is it's similar to
The Last Story and you led on from it in
the sense that people are people like
Russell Brand are taking advantage of a
climate basically of kind of fear and
mistrust they exists in our society
because of the massive disparities of
power that do exist there right there is
you know a massive coordination in terms
of the power of small number of media
organizations it is difficult for
smaller media organizers to get through
that there are you know a lot of very
troubling things that um have been you
know done or covered up by people at the
top of our society whether we're looking
at you know billions of dollars
distributed to private corporations
during the financial crisis or covid or
whatever people know that the people at
the top of our society do not have their
best interests at heart and often lie to
them about what is actually going on and
that is what fuels conspiracy and Kevin
the trouble is when when we had the
chair of the Parliamentary committee uh
Caroline dionage I think it is and she
wrote to the bosses of all the of the
big tech companies to say you've got to
stop monetizing this guy that kind of
overreach by politicians plays
completely into the hands of Russell
Brand and his followers that's like
clear evidence of a of of the State
trying to overreach isn't it I always
feel very uncomfortable about
politicians using their positions to
exert uh pressure that way however if I
was running a company I wouldn't want my
ads on his on his Channel at the moment
when he's facing these accusations and
one way he's right it is bigger than him
but not in the way he means and the way
it's bigger is one of the reasons
um only one in every hundred reported
rapes in the UK end up in court with a
prosecution is because too many powerful
men and the authorities of uh
not as amazing in the interests of women
right I mean what is amazing is the BBC
revealed a couple of days ago a news
story involving a woman who went on the
record saying that in Los Angeles he had
come into a a bathroom uh where she was
and he'd exposed himself to her and said
I'm gonna you know sexually have sex
with you and she said no you're not was
disgusted or whatever and she's only now
come forward and said it again
allegations but what's extraordinary is
it then 25 minutes later he's on the
Airways on the BBC joking about this and
saying you know the guy says 25 minutes
ago he was showing a woman you're Willy
right so the BBC's got this big archive
now stuff yeah well they've just
broadcast almost confessional stuff from
your brand about this stuff why were
they not doing more standards and
practices at the time uh
mistakes frightened uh in all of him
whatever it is look his free speech he
was he was that he was a darling of that
subject
of Britain
was it because of the time he was a
left-wing darling oh for goodness
have we not seen any right wing uh
people
you know allegations
you're missing my boys
the left wing decided he was a superstar
he attended Guardian editorial
conferences sitting next to the other
surrounding Ross Bridge who's now
outraged by him he wrote a column for
the guardian for seven years he appeared
at their conferences he edited the new
Statesman he was on all this stuff right
he was he was being given and yet they
they must have known about the stuff
that was going on on the BBC at the same
time we didn't know what the Guardians
think hang on expose himself to a woman
there was a there was a culture of
permissiveness where powerful men could
joke about sleeping and abusing and
flashing to women it was all considered
a laugh yeah you go back in British TV
you think of Benny Hill yeah all right
just think of it you can come up happen
to people on the right too but I want to
make the point his free speech is not
infringe because he can say what he
likes but we
cannot say it because of libel laws
which he uses defamation laws which he's
been very ready to do before and also
there are just legal restrictions now
because police are getting him you know
raises a lot of issues I'm just glad the
police are now investigators we may get
to the bottom of it where it becomes
irrefutable right if there's a proper
legal process I would hope we get to the
the facts and the truth uh muscle not to
diminish the accusers they may well all
be telling 100 the truth but we know
also sadly sometimes accusers do not
tell the truth you've got to be fair to
everyone whoever they are um let's turn
to uh John Federman who's this senator
in America who's obviously had a lot of
health issues but they've now changed
the law not the law they've changed the
rules of the Senate that you can now
because he says he gets triggered by
having to wear certain clothing to work
because of his condition he now can go
in dress like this and he's been wearing
shorts and hoodies and all sorts of
stuff I mean Kevin even you now now
appear on television in a smart way even
you put a jacket and shirt on right even
here when we drop when we drop the
standards of things like the U.S Senate
it'd be like a British Parliament if
you've got somebody there saying I get
triggered by wearing suits and we saw
someone coming in in shorts and a hoodie
come on the Chain they changed actually
in the British Parliament the House of
Commons and the Chamber the rules on
having to wear a tie because it was an
MP who couldn't uh fix a tie because of
a medical condition look it's between
him and his constituents the people who
elected
elections go in public and moon members
of the public or pull down his trousers
I'm sorry the reason why you you are you
have you need to act and dress like like
the uh like you have respect for the
offers that you occupy it's not very
difficult to put on a shirt
well I'll tell you hang on what freedom
of expression no we have freedom of
speech freedom reports those are
supposed to be no no those are the
liberal rights upon Which democracy
British democracy what's founded we are
on this show all the time talking about
the importance of free speech the
importance of protecting against the
despotism of the States freedom of
expression falls into that category as
well
my mother my mother always said to me
dress as if you're gonna meet the queen
if you go to work dresses if you're
going to meet the Queen's a pretty good
rule right but if you're a Republican
and you think the queen is just the same
as anyone else
dress like earlier what was funny was a
New York Post and a journalist ran to
all the top restaurants in New York
dressed like I am in the hoodie and
shorts and most of them said you're not
coming in here so it's very funny uh